there is a  hospital slash health care system in  colorado  which is saying that they are going to  be denying transplants to unvaccinated  people  in quote almost all situations this is  really something else when we say  transplants we mean organ transplants  and they are saying that  other than in rare exceptions  if you were not vaccinated against covet  19  you are not going to get a um  transplant  if you need one  as a result of covid and what the policy  really points to are unfortunate  mathematical realities it's horrible  that these are the realities  but if one is unvaccinated  um and you  uh become very sick or need an organ  transplant your odds of making it  are lower